préparez vous à faire un voeu cette nuit
si le ciel est clair
vous aurez peut-être la chance
d'observer une ou plusieurs étoiles
filantes
en réalité ces objets célestes n'ont
rien à voir avec les lointaines étoiles
qui scintillent au firmament
le phénomène se déroule à seulement 70
kilomètres au dessus de nos têtes
chaque année dans sa course autour du
soleil la terre traverse des zones un
peu plus poussiéreuse
ces poussières ont été laissés par des
comètes qui se déplace dans la galaxie
vous savez des boules de glace et de
poussières précédées ou suivies par une
chevelure et nous que quand la terre
traverse l'une de ses régions
les poussières pénètrent dans
l'atmosphère elles subissent
d'importants frottements et finissent
par entrer en combustion générant ce que
nous appelons une pluie d'étoilés
filantes et une capsule pour des cons
finis
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleu vous pouvez
également voir ou revoir celle des jours
précédents en cliquant sur le côté gens
réalisent une nouvelle par jour mais
pour être sûr de ne louper aucune et
bien abonnez vous et activer la cloche a
lieu demain
et n'oubliez pas nous sommes confinés
mais on reste en lien